Another segment that we love to do on this show,
which I can honestly say
today feels like such a luxury
and a privilege
is of course our food news.
(cheering and applause)
There is an LA institution at this desk today.
This hot dog dynasty has been serving
Hollywood hot dogs since 1939.
And it is still going strong
on the corner of La Brea and Melrose.
I am honored
as someone who grew up in 1975,
right around the corner from Pink's hot dogs,
from Pink is Gloria and Beverly Pink.
(Applause)
Oh my god!
What?
We have
Whoa!
Those are some really big wieners.
This is our newest, most favorite hot dog.
It's the Drew's News dog and it's officially on the menu.
We're gonna have a Drew's News hot dog on our menu
at Pink's.
I-- First of all, I can't believe
that we get to be a part of the institution for Pink's.
I mean, I was, first of all,
the history is so fascinating.
Your family migrated from Russia.
Romania and Russia.
Romania and Russia,
opened up the hot dog stand as a cart.
Yes.
It was a pushcart
and they were lucky in those days to serve 50 a day.
Today, we serve about 2000 dogs a day.
Wow! I was just going to ask
82 years in business, how do you do it?
You do it by selling 2000 hotdogs a day.
That's right. That's right.
And we are humbled and honored
that people will wait in line for those dogs.
Right? Because it is an iconic institution
and Michelle Obama has come there.
Yes! That was a funny story because we were,
actually Beverly and I were there
because Japanese TV was showing up
to talk about Pink's
and somebody came up to me
and showed me his credentials.
They were the secret service.
They said, somebody very important is going to be here
in about 20 minutes.
And we said, who is it?
And they said, if you live on this planet,
you'll know who it is.
And it was Michelle Obama and her daughters and her mother.
And then Bruce Willis proposed to Demi Moore there.
Exactly.
Really? - Exactly.
Is that fun?
It hit all the trade papers. Yeah.
And another one,
Michael J. Fox got his call for family ties
on the payphone that was in front of Pink's
For reals?
He used to hang out so much at Pink's
that he referred to Pink's as his office.
And got the call to be Alex P. Keaton
right then and there.
Exactly.
Yeah, that's a legendary scale. - How cool is that?
The P stands for Pink's.
That's right! Alex Pink's Keaton
(laughs) Right, right.
Can I just ask what's on a Drew's news hot dog?
Yes, this is our giant 12 inch jalapeno dog
filled with jalapeno.
So it got a kick of, a little bit of a kick.
Just like the news.
Mustard, onions, our famous Pink's chili,
shredded, cheddar cheese, and bacon.
(gasps)
I love it, I mean--
Quite a feast. It's quite a feast.
Well, we love Pink's and we're so happy
the Pink's family is back,
and it is going strong opening after the pandemic,
the lines are continuing around the block.
(applause)
Thank you so much!
A hot dog is not a sandwich.
(laughter)
Thank you for saying it.
Seth, I just can't thank you enough
for gracing us with your presence.
I'm sure you have a lot of requests.
No, I'm very happy to be here.
But, You know what Seth? I'll say this.
It ain't no fun without the bun.
(uplifting music)